[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the assistant
comment editor at the telegraph olivia
oatley and the columnist at the guardian
zoe williams welcome to both of you
so to the front pages then let us start
with the financial times sunac defends
10 pension rise as teachers threaten
strikes ever pay reach the front of the
ft while tomorrow's telegraph also
focuses on the threatened teacher
strikes quoting zahawi who believes such
a strike would be unforgivable
the rail strikes lead the guardian
reading talks to end the rail dispute
breakdown in acrimony the times also
focusing on developments in the ongoing
rail strikes with the headline union's
pile pressure on bosses after a 7 pay
deal that's the deal between mersey rail
staff and the transport salaried staffs
association
the metro leads with the nationwide
polio alert the traces of the incurable
polio virus have been found in britain's
water system
tomorrow's eye also has that story on
its cover with the headline polio found
in britain for the first time in 40
years
very different story features on
tomorrow's daily star a psychotic
seagulls holding me hostage is their
headline that is i can't believe we're
explaining this a story about a seagull
which attacks one poor fisherman every
time he goes outside
just him
anyway a reminder that by scanning the
qr code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so
let's bring in our guests for the
evening olivia and zoe welcome to both
of you um zoey why don't you kick off um
it really is a case still of inflation
uh hitting record levels 9.1 percent you
know the teachers now threatening strike
action which will come on to a minute uh
the rail strikes ongoing um well the
times picks up on one strike settlement
uh which um the paper says piles
pressure uh elsewhere uh with the
pressure we're seeing
so basically there's the the in
liverpool the drivers have got a deal of
seven percent which some which
commentators are called fanciful if
other
people on the rail network think they're
gonna have that match now that is high
by the standards of pay rises the
docklands like railway um
the driver has got an eight percent pay
rise in
in similar circumstances but i think
what's important to keep in mind is that
as you just said inflation is at nine
percent so even seven percent is an
effective pay cut eight percent is an
effective pay cut so the idea that
that you know liverpodly and drivers
have got this extraordinary deal which
could never be replicated elsewhere on
the network is itself quite fanciful and
there is a very kind of
there's a very peculiar dual narrative
going on where
we're asked to
accept that these pay rises sound
extraordinarily large at the same time
as accepting that they still won't match
inflation and so they are still an
effective pay cut and i think that is
probably
the difficulty with all the talks
breaking down you know
the talks are being held certainly from
the network's point of view along old
school lines that seven percent sounds
like a lot five percent sounds like a
lot they were used to playing kind of
three percent increases but actually in
times like these anything less than
double digits is not a pay rise well to
be fair the national rail strap we've
been talking about is not just about pay
it's about a lot of changes which are
also unacceptable to the to the rail
workers but what about the spout we saw
today between the rmt who accused the
transport secretary grant chaps of
wrecking the negotiations and he uh
saying that was a plain lie i mean you
know the acrimony the backdrop of this
uh is also making the front pages of the
newspapers as well olivia
yeah um the relationship between grant
chaps and the unions is very bad i think
part of that is because he didn't
meet them face-to-face he didn't uh sort
of try and
nip the problem in and blood right at
the beginning you can see nadim zahawi
is already sort of
making his stand against what a
perceived potential teacher strike in
the future grant chaps didn't do that at
all um so the background's very bad it
makes the government look a bit weak um
and now you know of course there's this
deal in mersey's side which makes other
rail operators think that it'll be
possible for them to get a similar sort
of deal um as zoe says obviously
compared to inflation it's not a huge
deal but the problem is if you do
enforce that across the whole of the
rail network then other workers across
the whole of the public sector
understandably as you can see it's
happening already are going to be
demanding pay strike pay pay rises uh in
line with inflation and
that will fuel more inflation um so
that's the problem that the government's
contending with and some ministers it
seems are doing a better job of it than
others i think saharwi getting in there
straight away does make a lot of sense
chaps has been a little bit all over the
place um and it feels a bit typical of
boris johnson's cabinet who quite often
seems to be made up of just sort of
who's been loyal to him over the last
few months or whatever um they don't
seem to be grasping the the nettle
so well let's move to education shall we
the daily telegraph is leading with that
and a teacher's strike would be
unforgivable in the wake of covid this
is the education secretary um mentioned
there zoe uh and certainly we spoke to
one of the unions today who suggested
that already teachers had effectively
lost between 17 and to 20
of their real terms salary and that
actually you know they do need to meet
inflation um after all the hard work
they've put in during the pandemics i
mean i know you you'll probably support
that but we're now talking about public
sector pay which costs the taxpayer
money
well look i mean there is certainly a
problem with the backdrop here the
freeze of public sector
salaries over the cameron osborne era
was really really significant to
teachers i mean i knew
couples one was a teacher one was a
doctor
who'd like taken an effective pay cut
because of the pay freeze of 40 grand
over a period of six years it's really
significant what happened and what it's
done effectively is to turn a lot of
people some of whom would have been
quite high up in their profession
probably quite small c conservative pro
certainly much more focused on their you
know work than on activism and it's
radicalized them by giving them a very
fair unfair pay settlement over a number
of years so i mean i feel for the
education minister because he's coming
out with this kind of very classic
rhetoric about what's unforgivable and
what isn't but a huge number of teachers
will just look at this and think
exactly how much
pay erosion do you expect us to take
exactly how much of a decline in living
standards do you expect us to take
before we do something and bear in mind
teachers are prepared to strike you know
they're actually quite you that their
unions are
quite ready to get to ballot them on
strike action and to take strike action
so
it's it's quite a gamble to think that
he did so how we can shame them into not
doing it i would be really surprised if
they didn't strike so how much um
wriggle room is there do you think how
much willingness is there um from from
government and the and the departments
to allow some sort of correction because
of austerity since since 2010 olivia you
know is there a sense that actually it
is due and given that there are so many
jobs vacancies actually eventually
you're going to have to start paying
staff aren't you
i think there will be you know the
government will enter into conversations
definitely um but i think the government
is keen to talk to teachers directly and
i think teachers um are prepared to they
they understand what children have gone
through most of the teachers who i've
spoken to aren't interested in striking
at all because they've watched the
children who they've teach they've
taught and nurtured over years really
really struggle over the covered
pandemic and want them to be back at
school learning and a couple of teachers
i've spoken to are quite worried about
the actions of the teaching unions which
they see as just
very politicalized and very radicalized
and not particularly interested in the
children that these teachers are
teaching so i think the government is a
bit worried about engaging in
conversations with unions as we saw over
the cover pandemic there were plenty of
the particularly militant um unions who
who you know didn't want teachers to go
back to school when it was obviously
completely safe when every other
industry was back in back in work they
didn't want teachers to be in the
classroom they kept finding reasons for
teachers not to be back in the classroom
and it seemed to be just because they
wanted to pick a fight with the
government so i think you know
radicalized unions aren't going to isn't
isn't going to be what makes the
government change its mind over these
things so i think yes there will be a
little bit of wiggle room perhaps
somewhere but but the unions are
probably going to make the matter a lot
worse
and we saw the financial times there uh
rishi sunak forced to defend uh the fact
that pensioners will get you know will
get ten percent effectively um you know
the accusation that actually pensioners
are more likely to vote conservative um
but benefits are also included in this
figure
but listen even if you say pensioners
are more likely to vote conservative or
less likely to conserve vote
conservative what this does is destroy
the argument which olivia very
elegantly just made if it's reasonable
to give pensioners a nine percent boost
a triple lock boost then it's not
reasonable to ask public sector workers
to live through a decade of pay freeze
and then take an effective pay cut you
know you can't have it both ways most
pensioners don't have any other income
as the argument as well isn't it no
that's not an argument is it because the
the triple lock of the pension
is to keep in line with inflation so if
pensioners need to keep in line with
inflation then so do wages and teachers
don't have any other wages you know
chain drivers don't have any other wages
all they've got is the wage that they've
got so it's effectively saying
pensioners are affected by inflation
whereas working people aren't now it's a
preposterous position and the idea that
working people are radical for asking
for an inflation meeting pay rise which
isn't a pay rise it's just your pay
staying the same
it's really
it it's just illogical and i think it's
in a logical position which you might be
able to maintain
were it not for this triple lock
situation in which sunak is saying that
it's necessary for pensioners but not
necessarily for working people so olivia
what
what what what are the political
benefits olivia of the government
holding the line on this and being so
vociferously against the rail strikes
what are they hoping to achieve by all
of that
well i do think there is an element of
the grey vote um and the conservatives
know that every party knows that that
that older people are just more likely
and willing to to go out to vote um and
so i think part of it is appealing to
them in the government's defense and i
think the triple lock is a bad idea and
i think it is completely logical and um
i agree with what zoe just said but from
the other side i don't think anyone
should be getting a a massive pay rise
in times of even though i know it
wouldn't count as a massive pay rise but
in times when inflation is going like
this i think it will just make the
economy worse and worse for everyone in
the long run um so i don't agree with
the trip a lot but i think you know the
argument that that rishi sunat would
make is that yes one thing pensioners
don't have any other source of income
also actually the state pension in this
country is nine and a half thousand
pounds a year um it's not huge and there
are pensioners i think there are quite a
lot of people you know myself among them
it's easy to imagine pensioners as as
rich people who who we happen to know
who who you know in our london circles
the the pensions that we know aren't
particularly
badly off but there are plenty of
pensioners who are completely reliant on
their state pension of nine and a half
grand that's one of the lowest pension
incomes in the developed world
so i can sort of see the need for for
raising the state pension but i do think
that that saying that pensioners somehow
need in a a
pay rise in line with inflation and
other workers don't is nonsense which i
think which is why i think the triple
lock is completely logical and
can't really
isn't sustainable okay we will we'll see
how this progresses uh obviously more
rail strikes to come both of you stay
there lots more to discuss including uh
the news that polio
found in britain for the first time in
40 years
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh let us rejoin our guest
this evening uh zoe williams and olivia
utley welcome back to both of you um the
i and the daily mail both leading on uh
the fact that polio has been found in
britain olivia and this is once again
stressing the importance of getting your
vaccine sorted too isn't it
yeah so polio has been found in sewage
samples in north and east london there
aren't yet any cases of polio but this
is the first time that a sample of polio
has been detected since i think it was
1980 and 1984 that was the last
transmissible round of polio and then it
was completely eradicated in the uk in
2003. so this is really alarming um and
you know it implies that there have been
people who we know that the children not
getting their vaccines was on the rise
and part of that was because of lockdown
um so there's going to be this renewed
effort to get children vaccinated
starting in in hackney where the samples
found and the rest of and the rest of
east london um and you know let's hope
we can nip it in the bud this time
because it's clearly a really horrible
disease with
lifelong effects so yeah let's hope
those vaccines get done yes um the eye
is saying that family doctors have been
put on alert
with unexplained paralysis because
that's the problem isn't it in in the
worst cases polio can paralyze or or
even kill and doctors the male tells us
most of whom will have no direct
experience of the disease we're having
to be given reminders of the symptoms to
look out for zoe
it's amazing i mean my aunt had polio as
a child and it was then the effects were
devastating actually she did have
lifelong she does have lifelong
paralysis down one side um but she's
91 i think
um so
that gives a sense of how long it is
since we've had to confront something as
serious and this is something you know
that comes up every single time there's
any disease of any
gravity
is that the worst
possible outcome is it is that it
affects children and affects children
permanently so yeah i can imagine it's
panic stations and
a vaccine drive and
you know
the 2010s have a lot to answer for
in terms of the anti-vaxx spirit because
it never had any basis
in science and it was it would be
absolutely tragic if it had lifelong
effects for people now
let's head to news of rwanda uh not a
not a plane or two this time
but it's time for choggam the
commonwealth heads of government meeting
um in which both the the prince of wales
and the prime minister are attending and
meeting and uh the question mark in the
telegraph i suppose hanging there is how
awkward might it be olivia
yeah because borisov says that this has
sort of been his flagship policy over
the last few months um and prince
charles was rumored to have said that
it's appalling
and now they're meeting and discussing
it for the first time and sources are
playing down the prospect of them
talking about rwanda but it hasn't been
ruled out completely so this could be an
awkward first first proper you know chat
between between boris and prince charles
and a sort of harbinger of things to
come because one day prince charles will
be king and how he interacts with with a
prime minister like boris johnson now
will be very interesting to see you've
got 30 seconds on the inside pages of
the express zoe which is the pioneers of
the windrush generation picturing uh the
duchess of uh of cambridge there
well this actually really picks up well
from the last story because you know
this speech by prince william is
basically a slap in the face to the
hostile environment i mean you know you
cannot as
the heir to the throne of england stand
up and say the windrush generation has
been peerlessly valuable to this nation
without that meaning something i mean it
means a lot
and i think it a lot of the kind of
empty rhetoric and i always thought
rwanda was gestural even though it was
horrible for the people who they tried
to deploy and i thought the go home or
face arrest fans by theresa may were
also gestural i think a lot of the
hostile environment is just empty
political gestures
the royal families against it apologies
for cutting in there we have run out of
time zoe williams olivia utley thank you
both very much indeed